- Honestly, if your name
is Shyamalay, Chalamet,
that's too much.
I changed my last name,
he should consider it.
He'd have a much bigger,
like the size of mine,
you know what I mean?
(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, welcome
to The Other Show.
I'm Sarah.
- And I'm Chris.
- And we are here talking
about episode four
with Hélene, Drew,
and Case Walker.
(applause)
- There's Chase.
- [Chris] He's here.
- He's here!
- [Sarah] Thanks for being here.
This was your first audition.
- Yes ma'am.
- Ever.
- Yes.
- Wow, thank you, Ma'am.
(everyone everyone laughs)
- I have to leave.
- [Chris] We'll
cut out the ma'am.
- This is your
first audition for.
- Yes.
- That is cool
and sucks to hear.
(everyone everyone laughs)
- This was my last audition,
and I was like Woo!
Thank God.
That was the final one.
- [Sarah] That was it!
- I have a school
dance next week.
Maybe Chase could be my date?
- I was doing musical.lys
on a broken iPod in my,
lip sync videos on a
broken iPod in my room,
and I just kind of started
going up, and my mom's like...
We went to the mall one
day and someone was like,
'Hey, can I get a
picture with your son?'
and my mom's like,
'What's going on here?'
'Cause she has no clue
what's going on either.
So then she got into
it, and that's kind of,
How it started, just in my
room, just doing what I like
and having fun with it, yeah.
- The gays are
turning on the vid.
They're saying it's quote
'so five years ago'.
(audience groans)
- That's the worst
thing you can be.
- There is an entire world
of people that you know
that I don't know are alive.
- Yep, yep.
- And people that we all know
and think are incredibly famous
- That I'm just like,
- that you've never heard of.
- [Sarah] Yes.
- So I was like, I want
to throw out some names
and see if you know
if they're a person.
Have you ever heard
of Helen Mirren?
- No.
- You've never heard
the name Helen Mirren?
- I've never heard
the name Helen Mirren.
It's like, usually,
I'll tell you
if I've actually heard them
or if I know who they are.
- No, this is great.
- That's great.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- What do you think
Helen Mirren does?
- She sounds like an actor.
- Okay.
- Good, good, good, good.
- Like sketch or comedy.
- Why do you want to say that?
- [Hélene] Skits or comedy.
- Jennifer Lawrence.
- Oh yes, of course.
- Okay I was like, that
could maybe even... okay.
- Wait, I have another one.
Do you know who Steve Carell is?
- Yes, I've heard his name.
I don't know who he is.
I couldn't, If you
showed me his face,
I wouldn't know,
but I know his name.
- Wow.
- That's cool.
- Do you know who
Timothée Chamalet is?
- No.
- Chamalet?
- [Hélene] Is that
not how you say it?
- Take a lap, take a lap.
- Do you know
- what is it?
- Do you know who
Timothée Chalamet is?
- Yeah, I do.
(everyone everyone laughs)
- But who's the other one?
- Now, give us people,
see if we know of anybody.
- Oh, see, okay...
KSI.
(concise no)
- What's that?
- A radio station.
- David Dobrik.
- No.
- No?
- It's not as fun this way.
- (everyone laughs)
This is cute.
- Okay, wait.
One more time, one more time.
- It's more fun the other...
- Yeah, we see what we did
to you, and we're sorry.
- Liza Koshy.
(concise no)
- You've never
heard of Liza Koshy?
She's getting really into more
like mainstream right now.
- Liza Koshy is
your Helen Mirren.
- What does a YouTuber do?
- Hélene, we can't...
(everyone laughs)
- We're not, we're not...
- Will they make scripted
stuff, or do they...
- Just for the record,
we're not that bad.
♪ 'Cause I think it's cool.
♪ My brother's gay
and that's okay. ♪
- So I remember like
right when we were
starting the shooting,
they were like, 'Yeah, so
we just need like 200 photos
of you in your childhood,'
and I was like, 'Oh God.'
And like, videos too,
and I was like, 'Oh no,
'I'm gonna have to like
watch a bunch of videos
'that make me sad.'
So I got a bunch of
them, and they were like,
'Hey, do you mind
if we reach out
'to some of your Facebook
friends from high school.'
- Yeah, sorry.
- I was just kind of like
'Oh yeah, those people
'I haven't talked to
in like ten years.'
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's reach out to
them, but it was like.
- Yeah, we just
sort of need photos
from anyone you've ever met
at any point in your life.
Ever, that's all.
- Yeah, I actually
reconnected with some people,
and I was like, 'Hey, I'm
on a show now, and I'm,
'Do you have any photos of
me being weird at parties?'
- If this keeps happening,
why do you keep showing up?
- Because one time out of ten
it really is a dying girl,
and if you don't show
up, it's bad optics.
And P!nk doesn't do bad optics.
She does near constant
aerial gymnastics.
- Okay, I don't want to insult
any of my fans here, but...
So I had a fan, I don't
know, it was this one girl,
and she was being
really extreme,
and in the DMs, she was
like, 'Case, I'm dying,
'you need to...'
And she was saying all
this really serious stuff,
and so then we went into it.
Because she was
doing it for months.
She was like, saying
she's gonna die
and that if I didn't do
anything, she would die.
- Jeez, yeah.
- [Case] It was very
serious and sad.
And so I was concerned,
so eventually I was like,
I'm not going to send
her flowers to, like,
someone who I don't even know
is real or actually dying.
So we ended up
calling the hospital
and seeing if the girl
was actually dying.
Then, a couple weeks later,
we found the photo online
that she had posted.
- Oh.
- She searched up,
like a disease,
and then took a
photo of a young girl
and put it on her page.
- That is so disgusting.
- It's bad, yeah.
- Whoa.
- [Chris] That's crazy.
- Yeah, it was pretty...
- And that became Brooke's
storyline in this episode.
- Thank you so much
for a great storyline.
- Yeah!
- Dear ChaseDreams, I've
been in the hospital
for seven weeks and
it's not looking good.
Could you send me a t-shirt?
You're my favorite singer ever.
Love, Rachel Klein.
- Poor girl.
Such terrible taste in music.
- I wrote to Nutella.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh boy.
- I wrote them, I was like,
"Hello, I love Nutella,
this is the greatest
product ever.
Thank you so much
for all that you do."
And they sent me coupons
for free Nutella.
- Whoa.
- Then when they sent me free
coupons, I was like, Hmm.
So I wrote, like,
Ben & Jerry's...
- [Sarah] Yeah, then you
were like, This works.
- [Chris] For sure, for sure.
- Like, where are my coupons?
- I remember I waited in line
at the mall for four hours
to meet Candace Cameron.
- To meet who?
- Candace Cameron.
- We have to go.
- You don't know
who that is, do you?
- I don't know who that is.
I'm like trying to remember,
there's a lot of people.
- She was on Full House.
- She's on Fuller House.
- (everyone laughs) Oh,
she's on Fuller House.
- Is she on Fuller House?
- She's the mom on Fuller House!
F*** it.
- [Hélene] Oh my God!
(everyone laughs)
- Okay, that's all, that's all.
- That's all the time we have.
This was a rough episode.
(upbeat music)